an ant is pretty stupid it doesn't have
much of a brain no will no plan and yet
many ants together are smart an ant
colony can construct complex structures
some colonies keep farms of fungi others
take care of cattle they can wage war or
defend themselves how is this possible
how can a bunch of stupid things do
smart things together this phenomenon is
called emergence and it's one of the
most fascinating and mysterious features
of our universe in a nutshell it
describes small things forming bigger
things that have different properties
than the sum of their parts emergence is
complexity arising from simplicity and
emergence is everywhere
[Music]
water has vastly different properties to
the molecules that make it up like the
concept of wetness take wet fabric if
you zoom in far enough
there is no wetness there are just
molecules sitting in the spaces between
the atoms of the cloth wetness is an
emerging property of water something new
only created by a lot of individual
interactions between water molecules and
this is sort of it many things interact
under a certain set of rules creating
something above and beyond themselves it
turns out that more is different this
different property is itself a new thing
and that new thing can couple with other
new things to repeat the process you can
imagine this as layers stacked upon each
other every layer made from more complex
parts atoms form molecules molecules
form proteins proteins make up cells
cells make up organs organs form
individuals individuals form societies
but how can something be more than the
sum of its parts
how do ants form the sort of cloudy
entity that is a colony by following a
rule set that produces order through
chaos for example let's look at how an
ant colony distributes jobs let's assume
that a colony shall have 25% workers 25%
caretakers 25% soldiers and 25%
gatherers ants communicate their current
job via chemicals for example the worker
and constantly secretes chemicals that
say I'm a worker when ants meet other
ants they smell each other to gather
information telling each other their job
and what they're doing both keep track
of who they met in the past now imagine
an anteater kills most of the gatherers
if this isn't fixed quickly the colony
will starve
many worker ants need to switch jobs but
how do you tell this to thousands of
them simple you don't our worker ant
will still meet and smell other ants but
it will encounter almost no gatherers at
all it counts too few gatherers until it
reaches a critical point and then it
changes its job the worker becomes a
gatherer other ants will do the same
until after a while there are enough
gatherers again the balance is restored
all by itself the actions and
interactions of an individual are random
you can't plan which ant will encounter
which other ant but the simple set of
rules is so elegant that economists many
operations emerge as a consequence on an
even more fundamental level hundreds of
millions of complicated molecules
interact to maintain a robust and
amazing structure of being with vastly
different properties than the sum of its
dead parts emerges the smallest unit of
life a cell
we still don't have a clear definition
of what living things are we just know
they emerge from things that are not
alive cells combine and cooperate they
specialize and respond to one another
and over time we develop into complex
organisms with remarkable capacities
your arms and legs and heart are an
incredibly complex and complicated
system made of trillions of individual
stupid things and yet we breathe digest
and watch YouTube videos
how do your cells know what to do
think of the pacemaker cells in your
heart billions of them need to send out
an impulse just at the right moment to
collectively create a heartbeat
our cells exchanged chemical information
with their neighbor cells to see what
they're up to and then decide what to do
if it's among a lot of cells that are
working on the same task it will start
working on that task as well and sync up
with them there is no master mind giving
commands just single units communicating
with their neighbors and acting
according to the feedback they get what
about our most important part what is
the thing that asks these kinds of
questions is our consciousness then an
emergent property of the cells in our
brain this question is too big and
important it deserves a video of its own
some things that emerge are hard to
define
you can't touch an ant colony only its
part it has neither brain nor face nor
body and yet the colony interacts with
the world just like colonies emerge from
ants things emerge from humans like
Nations
what actually is the nation is it its
population is it it's institutions its
symbols like its flag colors or anthems
the physical things it makes like cities
the territory it occupies all of these
things are fluid populations change and
our replace institutions come and go
cities can be constructed and abandoned
borders have changed all the time for
most of history and symbols get replaced
by new symbols a nation has no face no
brain no body our nation's not real then
of course they are just like ant
colonies nations interact with the world
they can change landscapes wage wars
grow or decline and they can stop
existing but they only exist because of
a lot of humans interacting with each
other but not just nations all the
complex structures that surround us
emerge from us even if we don't intend
to we are constantly creating
communities companies cities societies
all of these things are entities that
have fundamentally different properties
and abilities than the pretty stupid
Apes they emerged from we don't know why
any of this happens we just observe it
and it seems to be a fundamental
property of our universe it may be the
most beautiful and wondrous property of
our universe
[Music]